[Music]
so we're going to be taking a look at
gates from one of the you know people
that really you should think about when
you say end games the third world
champion in history
Jose Raul Capablanca was born in Cuba a
long long time ago and he won his World
Championship in 1921
now Capablanca is famous for many
reasons first of all okay he was one of
the you know the reasons the Cuba is
still a chess powerhouse is that well
people really lived up to the legacy of
kappa blanka cuba is one of the
strongest countries in the world despite
the fact that they don't have as many
resources as others and
capablanca had a very unique style
unlike many players of his time he
wasn't particularly known for his flashy
tactics or for his advanced opening
ideas although he had a few he did a
revolutionize chess he didn't come up
with new hyper modern trends the way the
nimzowitsch already did he was more of
what people call them a human chess
machine he would just grind people down
with technique more or less in the lines
of our current and reigning world
champion Magnus Carlsen the similarities
of Carlsen in Capablanca there exist of
course Carlsen place at a different
level he is much stronger he has about a
hundred years of chess history that he
can rely on but the idea is kind of the
same kappa blanka was known as a player
that took very small advantages and was
able to convert them and as such he was
actually particularly known for his end
gameplay Capablanca sin games were
probably the most feared out of his time
the only player that was close was
probably Akiba Rubinstein out of outside
of him well kappa blanka was definitely
an in-game monster we're going to start
with one of the most classical and a
typical kappa blanka type of games in
which you
wasn't necessarily winning but just by
grinding up his opponent and creating
problems eventually he cracks under
pressure and we're going to be taking a
look about not against any random
opponent we're going to be taking a look
about hostile kappa blanka was white
against alexandre yoking or as known in
america alexander alekhine in their
World Championship match of 1927 this is
the 20 round 29 I believe yeah they're
long they're long matches and I even
though a yoking was eventually the
winner of the match he emerged
victorious as the world champion from
this there were a lot of interesting
bout and kappa blanka did win a really
nice game here so we're going to skip
over the opening because it's not
entirely relevant to the course of what
we're talking about but just know that
this is trash nobody plays like this
anymore the idea of playing see 6 and a
6
once the bishop is already developed on
g5 only really works if you can quickly
take on c4 and protect the pawn with b5
known as the bad vinick's systems or the
any kind of semi sloth is still viable
but if you let white play 3 basically
they get all of the good stuff out of
the opening they develop the bishop
outside the pawn chain and black doesn't
really exert any pressure in the center
it's just a little too passive but ok
this is a you know 1927 so don't blame
them so Queen 8592 somehow transposed
into a Cambridge Springs which was
really popular in this match and after
Queen c2 takes on c4 of course I cannot
take on c4 because this bishops hanging
I have won a game of blitz like that
before Bishop f6 tx-94
and we got eventually this kind of
structure and I want to point out that
even though this is not the end game
kappa blanka had a pretty unique style
in that he didn't necessarily try to
kill you but he always was aiming
towards an ending game
he was always aiming his pawns his
pieces towards a potential endgame
position in this case he's using one of
the most typical ideas and
nowadays the minority attack where you
have two pawns on one flank quickly
rushing to attack a majority on the
other side therefore it's called the
minority attack in order to trade off
pawn Sammy one weekend we'll see exactly
how this happened during the game any
question somebody somebody okay
nevermind so be six castles a five and
again I'm not going to spend too much
time with the opening here but 95 was a
very nice move as you can see there were
a lot of alternatives from this position
and 95 was really really nice that the
idea is that 95 in certain occasions
will be a threat since after 95 you
cannot take the night because there's
the pin on the Queen and it would weaken
the c6 pawn severely so okay take stick
stick zombie one takes only one and rook
c8 which is particularly good because it
depended upon one c6 again I'm going to
rush through this a little bit take some
b7 take some d7 94 and we're going to
begin really analyzing the game here
after 95 we have a position that is
obviously better for white after the
move d5 White's pressure is quite severe
it's very difficult to hold the Queen
side together for example if you play C
5 then after DC 5 Bishop c5 rook d1 the
pin down the D file would cost black
upon since there is no way to defend the
night and taking with the b-pawn looks
more or less suicidal you're allowing me
to have a particularly strong past pawn
in the B file while the pawn to c5 after
it's blockaded by my queen is only
blocking in your bishop so this wasn't
exactly what all you're looking was
trying to do unfortunately after pawn
takes Queen takes we have a different
situation
notice how capablanca structure and he
was known for this the structure was
always really good he was it was
difficult to provoke up a bunker into
making a weakness in his structure and
it's really solid it's a structure that
prevents black from playing actively it
kind of
refrains any kind of counter play and
meanwhile aliens structure is
particularly weak because the point of
v6 well it's isolated its backward and
it's hard to defend we're going to see
how kappa blanka even though he doesn't
play as well as for example Carlson with
play nowadays he did play with an
incredible amount of precision for the
time and cause real problems
Ricca aid was played indirectly
defending the pawn ob6 due to the pin on
the a file rooks e1 Andrew K 5 obviously
attacking the Queen Queen c6 and Bishop
e3 which was not considered correct but
already the position was unpleasant
rugby 1 and Bishop f8 after takes on d5
takes to d5 finally kappa blanka 1 1
point and what comes from after this is
a very technical face sometimes winning
a position where you have an advantage
is not so easy and I this one is a
particularly hard position to win why
well because already the amount of force
is limited even though you did win one
pawn now black suddenly has no
weaknesses there's nothing to latch on
to the King side is relatively safe the
knight doesn't seem particularly more
powerful than the bishop you know why
it's active he's not really threatening
anything so there's going to be a lot of
patience involved in winning this kind
of end games this is not exactly a sheer
event game like we saw last week this is
not as flashy or as exciting but it is
also important for a chess player to
have the quality of excelling at
dispositional kind of end games h5 and
kappa blanka was always able to really
maximize the power of his pieces so the
knight he tries to figure out where he
wants to go where it's going to be more
powerful he decides 'hey v is the best
so Knight c4 is played Queen e4 now
notice that kappa blanka doesn't allow
the move h4 he doesn't want to trade off
too many pawns in the endgame when you
are defending that means that you have
for some reason an inferior position you
have less pawns or whatever if you are
defending it's normally a useful
all idea to trade off pawns the less
amount of pawns in the endgame
the easier it is to hold there will be
more opportunities for you to sacrifice
something for the last remaining point
of your opponent which just might make
the game a draw conversely you don't
want to trade pieces if you're defending
and you're down material you don't want
to trade pieces but you do want to trade
pawns questions about that yeah so Roxy
795 Queen c8 King G to Bishop d6 row k1
you know with a little threat of Route
k-8 pinning the Queen and now here I
believe that got Leo Hina had no choice
by drug p7 if queen b 7r okay a check
bishop f8 takes takes troop d8 would win
instantly because there's no way to
defend against 97 so instead of this
route p7 was played and then 93 the idea
is that kappa blanka felt his knight
would be eventually superior to the
bishop and he wants to prevent too many
trades for example a queen endgame would
be really really difficult to win even
though you're up a pawn I mean it's you
don't have a passed pawn it's very hard
to create one and your King would be
somehow weakened so you wants to at
least keep the knight g6
route k c6 Bishop f8 rook c6 and after
rook c7 you decided okay I'll trade
these guys but keep the knife Bishop g7
shark cage 7 9 f3 threatening 95 check
Bishop f6 forced and now kappa blanka
you know this is where he starts playing
really really well and this is where
this is kind of kind of end games that
you know eighteen hundreds to 2300 so I
would say let's slip all the time
because it's not a an easy thing to
handle and of course below 1800 well
sometimes they lose it and the point
here is that you need to create a
passport creating a passed pawn is
clearly the way to make progress in this
position however it's not trivial for
you to do so as soon as you put your
pawn on d5 which is the most logical way
of creating a passed pawn you're going
to have to be worried about the blockade
there's going to be a dark square
blockade on the squared d6 so you want
to put your pieces in such a way that
you're already trying to rip apart the
blockade
if for example you push efore d5 too
quickly and somehow your queen is stuck
defending the pawn from the a8 square it
might become impossible to rip apart a
blockade instead kappa blanka first
retreats this Queen to the better
squared d3 where it will push the pawn
from behind now immediately there's the
threat of d5 because the Bishop's
hanging on f6 right so there's a little
pin King g7 Queen d3 Queen B 7 + e 4 now
that the queen is behind the pawn it's
easier to push play d5
Queen C 6 H 3 Queen c7 d5 takes takes
and now a yogi who was not exactly a
fool came up with a very interesting
idea he played the move Queen C 3
realizing that if he tried to block a
like this then after Queen C 4 and the
addition of the knight now that I have a
passed pawn might prove very difficult
to hold instead Queen C 3 was played and
now here we have a very interesting
situation should white trade Queens or
not
why not well yes or why not it's a
little too soon yeah
okay
yeah there's a lot of arguments that
would say that keeping the Queen would
have been stronger this is probably one
of the little differences that would
make carlson a better endgame player
than kappa blanka is that he has as I
said a hundred years of history to
really learn from other people you know
this is 1927 and games were not exactly
refining the back then we still hadn't
had this theory by Rupe I find and a
verb och and all this end game manuals
like my diver at ski that would explain
basic things like this people were still
trying to figure it out Queen d1 was the
best move in this position keeping the
Queen behind the pawn as he started in
order to try to push it as far as
possible before trading off the Queen's
the problem is that when he trades off
the Queen's too soon the King can come
and march in a little too quickly and as
was pointed out the knight isn't
particularly well placed if for example
after I traded Queens I could magically
put my knight on e4 immediately then
maybe this would make sense but as it is
it doesn't really help Capablanca
however just because an endgame is drawn
doesn't mean it will end in a draw still
black has to prove that this is a draw
it's a very difficult position
nonetheless here black has good chances
to hold the point is for now controlled
if I push it then King f6 and okay I
capture the pawn it doesn't it cannot go
too far but on the other hand for now
White's a little bit controlled so back
to basic end games the king must come
into the game the night well it's kind
of on the way so the King takes the long
route King f1 trying to go either to e4
or c4 can you have six King e2 strong
move Bishop b4 94 and now kappa blanka
has to play very precisely to try to
create chances if he misses even one
step it will be a very easy draw 94 is
important to be played in this position
as king e5 is impossible due to the fork
on c6 right yes
everybody okay so since there's no
kingly five Bishop c5 Knight c6 and
kappa blanka kind of mad
she keeps this king away with just this
night on the pond the night controls be
5 and e 7 while the pawn it self-defense
c 6 creating some kind of barrier for
the king on f6 king f5 and now again
kappa Blancas as precise as possible
if f3 to keep the king away from me for
h4 is very inconvenient as after g4 the
King comes to f4 and takes my h3 pawn
importantly the king must go to f3 kappa
blanka pushes back Ali Oh King it alone
he has no choice but to retreat g4 takes
takes and now one of the bigger mistakes
of Paleogene in the entire match this is
an game's been analysed plenty and I'm
not going to bore you with all the
details but most people think that it
would have been a draw after for example
Bishop d6 the idea is that if the knight
moves it gives up the v square whereas
if the King moves it probably allows
King g5 again the idea would be to play
f5 since as we talked about reducing the
amount of pawns it's a good thing for
the defending side he wants to trade off
the Jeep on for the f1 there's not a lot
of pawns remaining and it's probably a
draw and the idea is that after 98 for
example instead of going King v79 b7
which we quite a complicated Bishop e7
would be a much better idea forcing the
knight back to c6 if 97 in this case and
king b5 of course King g5 was played and
here kappa blanka played 95 which a Leo
can probably just did not see and the
surprising thing about this move is that
now you cannot defend the pawn on f7
well let's look at the variations if
king of 697 forks the night the king and
the bishop
if f5 the good move t6 takes on g4 King
G 2 now again if you take check right so
for example Bishop b6 then Knight d7
King f5 for King f6 does not matter
for example King f6 Knight c6 and the
night alone pushes the pawn forward to
the last rank as it controls the aid but
it also prevents the King for meddling
by keeping it out of even so somehow
this night you know like magic is able
to push the pawn forward without the
need of help of the king if f6 then we
have a simpler version check King h4 and
d6 simply wins as I will play d7 on the
next move and if the bishop moves away
then I could technically take on f7 even
though that's a little more complicated
than it should be the correct way of
winning would be simply d6 again pawn is
poison because of the four point of
seven
King f6 d7 now if Bishop e7 knight c6
again threatening d8 and if King e7
correct this Knight takes f7 the knight
is obviously poisoned because I would
promote to a queen for free and if 1967
95 check wins the last remaining pawn
for black giving you a 2 versus 0
majority on the King side which is
easily winning so
95 was kind of a bolt from the blue it's
kind of unexpected that this night alone
can dominate so many pieces at the same
time and push the pawn forward without
the help of the King a Leo King probably
isn't a little bit of shock played
Bishop d4 and after Knight of 7 sharp
king of 698 he found himself in a
completely lost position the knight will
regain his powerful square on c6 and now
black simply losing the pawn on f7 Erica
Blancas technique was always really
really brilliant after Bishop e6 96
Bishop c5 a Leo King was basically
trying to make up a Blanca proved his
advantage it's true that he's up to
pawns but it's not entirely clear how to
make progress the king is still
sheltered a little bit out of the way
and it's stuck defending this pawn on f2
meanwhile the pawn on d5 cannot move the
knight must remain on c6 to prevent king
e5 so it doesn't seem like there's any
concrete way but Capablanca he never had
any problems for this kind of positions
in a situation where there's not many
pawns left he actually sacrifices one of
them King f4 more important than the
pawn is the quality of the remaining
pawns and this allows the King to
support the D pawn and win the game if
for example g5 check then after simply
retreating I blocked out g5 for my
opponent so for example in this position
if I go kini to king g5 is an issue
because the King comes forward but
because I played king f4 and you play g5
I can simply retreat and after king e to
f3 go around with the king the knight
defends 'if I've the pawn takes care of
these two squares g5 is blocked so the
King is basically incarcerated by his
own open g5 for this reason Bishop takes
f2 was pretty much the only practical
chance check King f7 check and now the
ugly decision between King g7 losing
track of the depot
after which d6 is immediately winning
for example Bishop d6 d7 king of 896 as
we've already seen in several examples
the knight dominating the king not
allowing it to go to e7 or what he
played in the game King e7 but after
nine things g6 check capablanca regains
one of his pawns King D six King e4 and
the two passed pawns are way too much
for the single Bishop and King Bishop g3
94 kimi-san King e5 and at any point
here a Leo King could really resign a
little trick at the end Bishop before
now not g7 because Bishop c3 Chuck wins
the pawn on g7 instead King defy
avoiding the little trap kingly aid and
d7 check the final distraction since
after King takes d7 the final remaining
pawn from white Queens at the end with
g7 g8 promotion and of course a win so
yeah it wasn't exactly like a hundred
percent exact that's not like every
single move that capablanca played was
the best but it was just the way that he
ground down his opponents he always make
them he always created the maximum
amount of problems and it was to me
really surprising that in this endgame
after he traded off the the Queen's he
was able to actually put in a locking in
so many difficult situations with just a
knight he just used the night it was it
that was it that was just a night and he
it did magic it kept the king at bay it
was forking the bishop all the time he
helped the D pawn and he made this
Knight look I don't know much more
powerful than it is he had a real real
knowledge for understanding where the
pieces went
this is his where we starting this yeah
this is his game this is the game kappa
blanka against raga zine who was already
quite a strong player he was Rhaego
Singh was not exactly Kappa Blancas
contemporary for most of their lives but
this is near the end of Kappa Blancas
life and the beginning of virgos
chess career and a couple bunkers up a
pawn but again it's not a trivial pawn I
mean the bish is pretty powerful yes you
have a passed pawn on a3 but still is
this the kind of end games that I see
people find people in this room you know
blunder all the time because it's not so
easy there they don't know what happens
and eventually you're up a pawn and then
you don't know how to win and kappa
blanka had this knack for grabbing this
kind of position looking at the wall and
saying my king belongs here my rook
belongs here my knight belongs here and
then somehow putting them where they
belong and winning and just notice where
the pieces are right now and where they
are in a few moves route B 7 B 4 Bishop
d7 f4 kimi-san King f2r ok 7 rooks e3
notice how he actually gave himself a
weakness on a3 by putting the allowing
the rook to attack a backward pawn but
it's actually good technique because it
restricts the pawn on c7 does not allow
him to go to c5 king D 6
you see if I would have been a threat if
I hadn't played before
rogue d3 very important move controlling
the King on d6 notice again that the
night is doing a little bit of magic it
doesn't allow the King to pass onto the
king the Queen side and 95 check is
currently a a threat King e7 King III
okay for rooks III king d6 a repetition
and 92 and now the knight reroutes now
that the rook is placed as good as well
as it can be g6 check here king d4
bouquet 6 check King the 693 again using
a little bit of tactics to just push his
opponent back if ro K 3 obviously 94
check is winning since this is hanging
so f5 was played in order to prevent 94
and then b5
again if Roque 394 check that doesn't
change I still win the exchange so Roque
a king c4 and notice that it's actually
it looks like he shouldn't be doing this
like he shouldn't be putting pawns on
white squares but he always knew that
restricting his opponent was sometimes a
little more important than the dogmas of
chess and games
Kamisha p6 here and now finally after a
while Rhaego Singh kind of cracks under
pressure
c5 check obviously I cannot take on c6
because this bishop is hanging but the
point is that after Bishop g8 the pawn
is lost but it doesn't matter it's a
little too late notice how easily and
kind of effortlessly kappa blanka
brought this King on g1 all the way to
be for black did nothing he has he
wasn't given the opportunity to do
anything in the meantime he was
completely dominated by the knight and
the rook and the King just kind of came
into the game as its supposed to by this
point after rook d3 the rook will
penetrate on d6 push in the King even
further back and with the weaknesses on
g6 and h6 it's pretty clear that this
game is going to be won by white there's
an extra pawn a lot of problems and now
there's two pawns and the rest was well
pretty easy and red goes in resigned he
always made it look really easy he
always made it seem like this anchor is
basic like why are you even looking at
this but they're not I mean you put this
in the position nowadays and even for
grandmasters it's not it's not so clear
there are many ways many tricks for
black and they were there are many ways
to activate the game he always made it
look really easy right
let me start okay so this is one of his
most famous uh double rope can game
kappa blanka was known as a player that
with a better structure man he just
wrecked people here he is black against
Ilya Abramovich who I'm not entirely
sure if this is the con
everybody talks yeah I think this is
this is D con and after route B 3 B 5 we
got this endgame it looks equal White
House one two three four five six seven
Black has one two three four five six
seven points equal right to rooks two
rooks doesn't seem like anything and yet
kappa blanka wins this easily easily
like like like this was a completely
winning position yes his structure
because of the reinforcements on c7 on
to d6
because of the half-open F file on the
half open a file it became very easy for
him to activate his rooks while it
became really hard for Khan to activate
his own and we're going to see how he
takes this little little bit of a better
structure and just crushes his opponent
Rukh ft to c5 King F to root K for King
III bring sticking in here means the
King in king d - now it's not entirely
sure what White's doing but it was
already hard to suggest a plan he's kind
of just waiting for kappa blanka to do
anything so Capablanca improves his
position now when you're trying to take
advantage of this kind of situations you
always want to play two flanks there's
this all Maxim by nimzowitsch that you
do not lose with one weakness you need
two weaknesses to target that way you
overload your opponent by defending one
of them while the other remains
unprotected if you only have one
weakness to attack all your opponent has
to do is concentrate on defending that
one weakness and he'll be okay after g5
h 3 h 5 kappa blanka already was playing
on both sides he's preparing to
breakthrough on b4
some point while also preparing to at
some point break on g4 and expose up and
break the structure on the kingside so
after work h1 check you need to route g8
we already see the beginning of the plan
G for crushing the structure on the
kingside route d3 now kappa blanka wants
none of this trading route business
route k4 rook hd1 g4 take sticks and
King III now another strong move rotate
shade taking advantage of the open file
that capablanca made for himself if pawn
takes g4 then a very clever idea after
rook g8 I would threaten to take on g4
the only way to defend us with the king
but after checking e3 rook F for what
not only does white lose the pawn on g4
he also loses the pawn on e4 notice how
nice
White's attack White's getting attacked
from the King side and the Queen side
with the rooks so rugby 3 was played
through cage - he didn't care about this
because this looks pretty bad for black
/ white rook d2 roopd for of course Khan
cannot trade rooks in this instance
because he needs to work to defend the
g2 pawn rookie to c6 defending this one
rook c3 and then g3 a very important
move in this position it looks a little
counterintuitive since you are trying to
open up the Kings side but the idea is
that now this weakness is fixed now it
has to be defended permanently on top of
that the point is already quite advanced
which means that in any pawn race this
pawn will be very soon to become a queen
rogue d3 rook h1 and after F for a nice
little maneuver again
rook f1
kappa blanka threatens the pawn on f4
and check normally this kind of stuff a
protected pass pawn is quite a good
thing in an endgame but kappa blanka has
arranged it so that the structure that
defends the spawn specifically d4 pawn
will vanish
pretty soon King f6 c3 text X and of
course d5 now this pawn is hanging which
means this pawn will be left undefended
B 3 C 4 Chuck 2x takes King III and now
well White's tied down I'll go for the
other weakness ok 1 king of 3 roque 3
takes takes and after King h4 White is
maybe trying to create some counter play
with g4 g5 + kappa blanka is no mood to
give anybody sing any counter play rook
c1 g4 check bringing the King back
taking back control over g5 and after
King G 3 D for these past pawns are
quite obviously more powerful than these
already blockaded pawns on G and F ro K
2 D 3 kg 2 rook e1 king f2 takes this
guy and rook f3 and King f3 and white
resigned some moves later but you know
he's down two pawns and there's like a
huge pawn mass going this way not this
way because that's not her phone smooth
again it seemed pretty equal it seemed
like okay this is probably going to have
be headed to a draw and then he just
made it look like white you know didn't
was playing checkers or something it
wasn't playing chess he just made it
look really easy and that was the that
was the magic of capablanca he took this
end games and he made them look so so
easy one of my favorite kappa blanka end
games and he well I kind of prepared
more than I should have
this one was nice but this is another
one
I want to show once again severely TARTA
cover this was back when kappa blanka
was world champion and this is the
position and I think that explaining
this this game about two moves from now
will make easier sense to everybody but
I want to point out that the concept
that kappa blanka thought of he had to
have seen from this position and i
thought that was really cool
he puts the pawn in g5 two week fix the
weakness on g6 we always have a very
complicated situation kappa blanka
stroke on h7 is very active but he has a
severe weakness on c3 that it's just
about to die his bishop is attacking g6
so for now black cannot really afford to
trade off c3 for g6 as the two passed
pawns in the king side would be a little
too powerful the pot on i-4 is also not
doing great so dark took over thought
this would be a good idea to play 93
check and after King f3 put the night on
f5
the idea being that after Bishop takes
I cannot take because King g4 it's just
winning but he thought that after pawn
takes well I'm going to take this next
move with Chuck and I'm going to be able
to create some kind of passed pawn but I
kept of like I didn't care about pawns
he cared about the quality of his pawns
and he thought that this pawn alone we
give him victory however the pawn it's
reinforcements so somebody has to come
and help him and that would be the king
king g3
sacrificing the phone with check but
after check king h4 it became an
sacrificing this pawn as well because
rook f3 you cannot defend this pawn
anymore g6 check King g5 White's up a
full two pawns down three if tartakower
decides to take on f6 but because of the
combined action of this King and this
rook blacks actually losing despite
having one of these pawns
if rook takes d4 than the simple king of
success already crushing there is no
good way of defending rook h8 you can
play for example King here but after
rook d7 it looks like you're going to
get made it right so instead King rookie
four was played so that after King f6
King g8 I can meet the move rook d7 with
rook e8 which would be a little unclear
instead a high degree of precision rook
g7 check first putting the King in the
corner rook takes e8 now threatening
rookie rook c8 which means Rukia is
forced now I take the time to regain my
pawn and after rookie four I go back to
f6
so after rook e8 we will have the same
situation but no pawn on f5 I simply
want that pawn for free and in if rook F
for check you allow me to bring my King
back into the center with King e5 after
rook here then again a nice little
detail g7 check if rook takes g7 rook
takes g7 King takes g7 King takes c6 the
endgame is easily winning you put the
King on c6 and kind of just marched upon
whereas black is way too slow to create
counter play even though material is at
the moment equal for this reason rook g8
King Jade was played and then okay kappa
blanka to the time to take on a 7 there
was no rush at the moment Ruchi one King
takes d5 and then kappa blanka went from
being down to
fons a few moves ago to being up to
pawns and now he is completely winning
king c1 or king d6 Roxy to d5 rook c1
Roxy seven and now the same game is of
course quite basic the pawns are just
rolling which will cost black his rook
in the game so again he made it look
really easy against everybody that he
played even though he and what really
struck me is that he had to see this
when you played G Phi like you have to
see that you're going to sacrifice two
pawns and that somehow your king and
rook are going to win you always have
this ideas that were that they worked
you know they just worked this is
completely winning g5 was the best move
and this is actually a mistake but even
if hockey not played the mistake the
position was already a little
uncomfortable and after takes takes the
endgame is equal if it wasn't for the
fact that after King g3 the King's a
little too powerful so you know we have
the example first on the audio King game
and now here with our decoder that it
doesn't really matter how many pawns you
have it matters the quality of those
pawns are in the end games out of time
we're just going to take a really quick
look at this endgame but yeah this is
what's also one of those end games that
it looked like okay whatever maybe white
has a very slight edge and then kappa
blanka won easily and by easily I don't
mean he won't quickly this is actually
moved 16 and somehow they tread it into
an endgame but you know 52 moves from
now black resigned and kappa blanka made
it look like oh why didn't you just
resign here I mean you were lost
he played rookie four and he just played
a wonderful endgame again I don't have
the time to like explain all the nuances
but there's a lot of details here on
fighting for the e-file the two
weaknesses on h7 and a7 that I lost
kappa blanka to latch on to them the
idea of playing King here King here in
order to move the rook around while not
allowing this rook to ever really go to
e5 and do the same
Cafe rookie - King e7r okay for Roque a
true k5 d5c for King the six check
grabbing that space King be 7 d 4 F 5
and a very timely rook takes c6 one of
my favorite kappa blanka moves it looks
stupid because it just fixes the
structure but he knows that he must
trade off the active rook and after
takes f4 it looks like it's difficult to
make progress because okay you attack
this one good for you but now what and
he just makes it look easy King CH King
D - king b 7r okay three swinging the
rook yet again for jailbreak h3 route g7
kingi - king a6 rook h 6o suddenly
there's another weakness on e6 rookie 7
king daeso and h4 and now it's basically
a little bit of Zook swung and the
addition of more attackers kappa blanka
switches the rook to the g file and
pushes this guy forward
a difficult position already beef I take
steaks and here he didn't take on here
because after King takes be 520 C 6 C 6
here here here he would have been lost
because of the route g7 threat he
couldn't afford to weaken the
second-ranked so Ruka fate was played
route g7 check here takes takes rook a
to check again gain more space King b8
takes on h7 and then it's just like
black didn't do anything he regains one
of his bones and again his opponents up
two points but completely lost this
pawns are nowhere near as powerful as
this one solitary guy King b5 route d1
h7 if rook h4 by the way I think the
easiest win was h7 and I'm threatening a
check and a a h8 where yeah if King e7
here then check and then I do the same
right so now the king is forced back and
now Rukia is unstoppable
so route d1 and some kind of desperado
but the King eventually hit and this 3
pounds okay there nothing for a rook
black resigned so again he always had
this like Diaz with the double rook end
games the rook end games where he knew
how powerful a pond was he knew the
power of dominating his opponent pieces
he knew the importance of the two
weaknesses where he was able to latch on
to the weakness on the Queen side forced
the King all the way there then move his
pieces around quickly to the King side
attach himself to the weakness there
and his opponent something they didn't
know what they were doing I mean they
just looked bad playing they looked bad
this guy looked bad it's like this was
equal and then he just lost easily but
that was the magic of capablanca he was
able to torture any player in any end
game and the reason he really reminds me
of Carlsen is because Carlsen plays
pretty much in the same style there was
an interview with Fabiano Khurana lately
where Khurana said yeah I mean I
analyzed this position with the Machine
and the Machine says it's equal but I
know I can't play this against Carlsen
that's impossible and capablanca was
very much in the similar way the machine
might say it's equal and it's probably
equal with perfect play but Capablanca
can perfect play versus opponent oh he
ain't no kappa blanka
[Music]
Oh
[Music]